- Are you a superstitious person?
I heard this about you.
- You know, well it
started, it started early
and actually it has to do with you,
funny you ask.
- Oh.
- I claimed I was responsible
for you winning "American Idol."
- Oh, did you call?
You called in?
Oh my god, you voted.
Oh my god.
- Many, many times of course.
- Oh, that's awesome.
- No, I was wearing, it
was like a random pink ring
and I was sure that it had
something to do with you winning,
I don't know how or why I interpreted it.
- You just kept wearing it every time.
- Every time,
and I was like it's gotta be this ring.
(Kelly laughs)
And then the next year,
when Ruben Studdard won,
I was like I'm wearing the ring.
I'm so powerful.
- Did it continue?
- No. (laughs)
- Was just lucky for me and Ruben.
- Yeah, I think it was just you and Ruben,
not the ring.
But yeah, that ring is no longer,
but I have random other superstitions
that I've developed.
Do you have any?
- Yes.
- Really?
I'm not like, I think mine's more OCD.
Yeah.
- Does your brain go to
like if I don't do this
a disaster's gonna happen?
- Yes.
- Oh yeah.
Like crazy.
- Me too.
Like if I go down a water slide,
I'm like, I don't wanna
go down a second time
but I have to because if I
don't do it a second time
the world is gonna explode.
- Because I believe in even numbers.
- Me too!
- I don't like odd numbers.
- Hate.
- Yeah, so I don't do
anything just once. (laughs)
- Like shopping, I have to touch fabrics,
even number of times, so
then people will be like
"What's she doing in the corner?"
And I'm like eight, 16.
(Kelly laughs)
- People are like she's weird.
- Is she okay?
I'm like, I'm great.